[Music]
continuing our footwork in Aikido series
so this week we're talking about
footwork and we're also going to throw
some time to income in there it's
important to understand where your
weight should be placed when you're
moving your body around so when you're
doing any kind of actually sabaki
understand inner and Sam where your
weight should be placed now understand
that there are many different theories
on where weight should be placed right
so when I was growing up there was this
big thing that you know everything
should be a 70/30 stance that's the big
thing you know so there should be 70% in
your back foot and 30% in your front
foot and this was a really common idea
there is no absolute standard for where
your weight should be placed but there
by placing your weight in different
positions it will enable different
things so understanding the details of
where you should be placing your weight
is really really important and will make
a lot of a lot of difference in your
footwork when I started learning I you
know I remember my teacher talking about
a 50/50 stance putting half your weight
in each foot and that was the perfect
position because that meant that you
could equally move right or left at any
moment as I've begun to study footwork
and my life I started to realize that
this is not exactly the ideal and when
we're talking about quick movement which
is what I can't show is be able to do
there is probably a likelihood of
placing your weight in a different spot
and in this video we're gonna talk about
that so where should you be placing your
foot your weight in your footwork in
Aikido so I'm gonna get Josh and we're
gonna talk about this now all right so
we're gonna talk now about where you
should be keeping your weight in your
stance so in your stance whether you
want to call it a rope Anoka mine or a
hug me
whichever how do you keep your weight so
Josh generally is gonna want to keep his
weight forward and I'm gonna explain why
that is yeah Aikido the idea is to
always be in motion so you should always
be in motion because if they're stronger
and more powerful than us if we stay in
one place that disables them to get a
very powerful genre so we don't want to
square up with anyone we don't want to
stay in one place at all we
also be moving now when you're
constantly moving whether you realize it
or not you're always keeping your weight
forward so if Josh stands like this like
he is right now with his weight in the
majority of his front foot he can easily
move his back foot like this now that's
the way that regular walking steps look
right so if I get Josh to come kind of
over here just to the side and just walk
through the frame for my second see now
when you watch him walking every single
time he's shifting his weight to the
front keeping it in front and then
taking the next step now notice if you
were to do that and shift his weight
back in between be a really weird way to
walk says maybe looks like some kind of
wedding a funeral procession something
special and formal or something but he's
not gonna get anywhere you're very fast
doing this and it's a weird way to walk
now every time he's doing this he's
setting his weight back so he thinks his
weight needs to be set back and she
comes with her a little bit more at the
center if every time he sets his weight
back like that that means before he
moves again yes to reset his weight
forward and move forward so instead of
doing that back for me and so instead of
doing that right every time you want to
make sure his weight is in the front and
this makes it really easy to take any
kind of a you Miyoshi step and that is
exactly what you're doing all the time
when you're regularly walking so a uni
action step is facilitated by keeping
your weight in front okay
now you might ask what if we need to
move off the front foot so if we need to
do Cydia she now because all the weights
up in his front foot it might seem like
oh man it's really hard to do that but
what Josh does is really simple instead
of trying to push off his back foot he
picks his front foot up when he picks
his front foot up he'll be springing
forward like that right and then you can
time that with his back foot so his
sukiyaki steps should be done by simply
picking up the front foot and letting
him spring across so by moving like this
he's getting the most efficient movement
for either Tsuyoshi or you mean Oishi so
yes you need me out she being our two
main ways removed he has to always be
able to go into either one of those
movements
now what if he has to do a 10 con from
this well if he has he wants to Tim Khan
always gathers pic of his front foot
turn it and spin around now notice when
josh is doing that he's pretty much
resetting the weight to the center every
single time
the 10 con that weights right in the
center again right so that weight never
moves off of this middle pillar the less
weight shifting you can do the better it
will be for you because every time you
shift weight that takes time so you want
to get used to moving from the foot
front foot consoling so you're always
setting the weight to the front foot how
much weight it's kind of a silly
question right so I could say you know
93% of your weight should be in the
front foot it doesn't really matter it's
whatever you're comfortable with as long
as the majority of your weights in the
front there's just a little bit of
weight in the back foot just to keep the
foot on the ground now you can do all
kinds of different spring steps out of
this all kinds of different stuff can be
managed from this but every time you
should be setting to this position
because this is how you naturally move
everything else should be modified
around this basic idea so your rope
Anoka mine should be from this position
with the majority to wait for it and
that will enable all of our basic
footwork patterns that we do in Ikea I'm
Christopher hein thanks for watching
we'll see you next time